[Music]
for decades anthony pelicano
was the best known private detective and
fixer
in hollywood his methods were
unconventional
and according to the federal government
sometimes illegal in 2002 federal agents
raided his office
and found practice grenades in c4
explosives
he served a decade and a half in the end
in jail a little more on wiretapping and
racketeering charges
he never ratted out anyone and he
learned an
awful lot in the meantime what an
interesting person he got out of jail in
2019
we spoke to him at great length about
what he learned in hollywood and in
prison for a brand new episode of tucker
carlson today here's part of the
conversation
so without betraying the confidence of
the people for whom you worked
give us your assessment of hollywood you
were at the very center of it
well you're talking about hollywood then
and or hollywood now the hollywood that
you knew
that you lived in hollywood it was
decadent
i mean everything that you could imagine
going on went on
you know and the reason i made so much
money is because people got themselves
into trouble
and needed to get out and they couldn't
go to law enforcement
you know so they would go to their
agents so they would go to their
managers or
their lawyers and lawyers would hire
give us a hypothetical problem that they
will want you to solve
no names but just like what what do you
kind of thing you're talking about
well you have the the metoo movement now
yeah there was no such thing as a me too
movement then
yeah you understand so uh you know
there were there were women who would do
whatever they could
to get you know next to a movie star
or to make money and and or athletes
especially athletes you know and sleep
with them
become pregnant so they get an annuity
yeah
or you know try to extort them
for large sums of money
you know you've done something with a
woman your wife doesn't know about it
you're a celebrity you could you could
you know
it could cost you a lot of money should
somebody disclose this
you know and then i'd come in and take
care of it
can you be slightly more specific
well how would you fix that problem you
got it you've got a professional athlete
or an actor a pregnant woman not his
wife you have to give that person who's
trying to do those things a reason not
to do it
and i gave them that free system
i mean that's just it's just as simple
as that i mean
you you fix the problem that's what i
did i
i was they called me fixer that's what i
did you know
how hard is it to make that case to the
person
being me not too hard at all but you
know but you you
you hit you i mean you have to they have
to look at you
they have to know that you're serious i
mean
you could do this the easy way or you
could do it the hard way
i don't give which way you choose
because you're going to do what i want
you to do at the end of the day
just that simple
how did they how how forcefully did you
have to make that case or did people
believe you well
well sometimes very forceful i mean you
know and
a lot of times people would go run to
other people to try to to intercede
you know and then i have to face those
people too but you know at the end of
the day i took care of it
and and by the way i always started out
as a gentleman
always always with reason i always try
to reason with people
i didn't get to the point where i had to
use other means
unless reasoning didn't work you know
so you just think about that what
what percentage would you say responded
to reason
not more than 25 percent
you had to go to plan b quite a bit yeah
this is an amazing conversation with an
amazing man
comes out of prison after 17 years ish
loving america and wiser sounds
improbable but it's true
if you watch it goes on for about an
hour it's a brand new episode of tucker
carlson today you will agree
anthony pelicano quite a quite a person
it's on foxnation.com
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else